how far away are we from AGI in your
mind I turn on my computer in the
morning I go to work whatever I happen
to name my assistant Joe and I say Hey
Joe what should I work on today and Joe
says well you know looking at your email
box there's seven companies that have
acute issues in your portfolio and these
three probably require a phone call
these four probably need some more
information based on what I've learned
so I'm going to send them requests for
this information and then schedule them
for tomorrow and Wednesday is that okay
boom and it just like kind of tells me
what I'm doing for the next 3 days when
when will that happen I was going to ask
you how you were going to Define AGI and
if you define AGI by just what you said
in that flow I think that we'll be at a
spot where you would be able to get that
within the next 1 to 2 years but what
would you trust the
recommendations